now it's quite clear that you won't
migrate your entire on-prem to the cloud
in the first go it makes a lot more
sense to migrate portions at a time
where appropriate as such you'll still
need a way for your on-prem systems to
communicate with your newly minted cloud
resource in this episode I'm going to
dive into Google cloud interconnect so
you can set up high-speed direct
connection to Google's Network for
faster data migration and an optimal
hybrid environment
stay tuned sure you can reach your cloud
resources with the appropriate VPC
firewalls and IPS in place but if your
hybrid architecture requires connections
with higher availability and lower
latency then a direct connection to
Google's network can offer more
reliability and performance so let's
look at how this plays out in reality
Black Friday is coming up and you're
expecting a significant spike in compute
resources to support the inbound traffic
to your site now if you have your
compute in a GC P V PC then you could
directly ping them from your on-prem
systems this would work technically
you'd get scalable systems in the cloud
and secure processing on Prem on the
backside however there are a load of
issues firstly this forces the
communication between your V PC and on
Prem to go through the public internet
communicating through publicly visible
IPs
most likely requiring you to secure your
traffic via a VPN in the middle secondly
this produces a significant performance
challenge the public Internet is not the
most performant and the extra overhead
of VPN on the packets could lead to less
than desired performance on a
significant shopping holiday what you
want instead is a reliable way to
connect your on-premise workloads to the
public cloud in a secure fast and
reliable manner in other words you want
to extend your on-premise private
network into a Google cloud over a
dedicated link the purpose of Google
cloud interconnect is to provide direct
fast connection between your on-premise
and Google cloud networks in a secure
fashion this security and performance
mixture is hyper important for a large
number of industries who work between
on-prem and in cloud for example data
migration replication disaster recovery
or other high performance computing
situations
in these scenarios you want to directly
connect your cloud systems while
extending your private on-prem network
to the cloud Google Cloud interconnect
provides a few options that can suit
your specific needs but the one I'll
focus on is dedicated interconnect which
provides direct physical connections
between your on-premise Network and
Google's network it works like this you
set up a cross connect between your own
router and the Google Network and a
common colocation facility if you can't
perform this then the official Doc's
have some options for you a BGP session
is configured over the interconnect
between the cloud router and your
on-premise router bgp is a protocol that
helps route traffic to subnets using the
shortest paths between edge routers
traffic from your on-premise network can
reach your Google Cloud V PC and vice
versa with dedicated interconnect the
immediate benefit as an enterprise-grade
connection to your Google V PC with a
dedicated 10 gigabit per second circuit
directly to a Google location moreover
you now have connectivity reaching
beyond Google's existing network
locations allowing you to scale
connectivity and save on your egress
traffic costs from your V PC network to
your on-premise network now you have a
way to transfer large amounts of data
between networks which can be more cost
effective than purchasing additional
bandwidth over the public Internet on
top of that you'll experience fewer
disruptions and drops with a predictable
user experience traffic between your
on-premise and VPC networks doesn't
touch the public internet meaning fewer
hops and potential points of failure
where it can be disrupted or dropped a
key benefit is that your VP sees
internal IP addresses can be directly
accessed from your on-premise network
with peering no NAT device or VPN tunnel
required now let's dive into how to
actually get that set up first let's
make sure you have a V PC setup for your
cloud environment if you haven't set
that up see the previous episode now the
first steps in using cloud interconnect
involve deciding if you want to use a
dedicated connection or a partner
connection while there are few nuances
between the two depending on your needs
the primary ones that I'm concerned with
our speed dedicated interconnect is
ideal for situations where you
more than a ten gigabit connection a
partner can be used for lower speed
needs access if your on-prem can't
physically meet Google's Network and a
colocation facility then you can use
partner interconnect now for the sake of
our demo we're going to use dedicated
interconnect because it's a little
simpler and can be cheaper in some
situations let's see what this looks
like go to the cloud interconnect
physical connections tab in the Google
cloud platform console select setup
connection select dedicated interconnect
and then select continue now select
order new dedicated interconnect and
then select continue specify the details
for your name location and capacity of
the interconnect now capacity is an
interesting metric the capacity you need
is determined by the number of 10
gigabit per second connections you can
order also called a circuit now select
next we'll skip over the redundancy
information for now but if you need that
please see the docs linked in the
description below specify your contact
information and review your order now
select place order on the order
confirmation page review the next steps
and then select done now it's important
to note that you are in fact ordering a
dedicated inter connect connection from
your on-prem to Google itself once
Google's done allocating things it'll
send you a confirmation email and send
you some Loa cfas
which you'll send to your vendor they
will provision the cross connects
between the google peering edge and your
on-premises network now once this is all
set up Google has to test your access
extensively before you'll be able to use
the interconnect directly there are some
complicated steps involved with this
that are specific to your setup so we'll
point you to the resource linked in the
description below to do that and skip it
for this video once all that is done
your final step is to configure your
VLAN attachments once Google verifies
you have a cross connect you see that
your interconnect is ready to configure
and you can click finish setup and
select add
an attachment give it a name my
attachment and select or create a cloud
router to associate with this attachment
it has to be in the B PC network that
you want to connect to
after you're done adding the VLAN
attachments select create the attachment
takes a few moments to create now you
can click configure to add a bgp session
to your cloud routers interface you give
it a name for the bgp session the public
or private
ASN of your on-premises router which
uniquely identifies each network on that
internet for bgp sessions an optional
advertised route priority the cloud
router and on-premises bgp IP addresses
are already allocated by the VLAN
attachment the bgp sessions are inactive
until you configure bgp on your
on-premises router if you're building
redundancy with a duplicate interconnect
repeat these steps for the second
interconnect and specify a different
cloud router for more info check out the
documentation now I want to know there
are a few nuances between how you use
cloud VPN VPC and dedicated interconnect
with your own VPN but that's all covered
quite well official Docs so again I'll
direct you there in the description now
that you have configured a dedicated
connection to Google's network the next
step is to protect your cloud instances
by configuring firewall rules if you
want to learn how to do that then stay
tuned for the next episode of Google
cloud networking end to end and remember
optimizing your network means freeing up
your bandwidth
[Music]